you tell me when this goes to yeah and
will okay on your mark get set go go I
start right now oh yeah
okay is it not fair because they're all
wrapped like should we have unwrapped it
oh L
back you can't guess anymore guys the
guesses are done there's a delay oh
that's why they're still guessing yeah
we could have a l moment no not right
now not right now no no I feel like we
should just focus okay we won't
even what it's not coming off
burritos no don't mess her up Do Not
Mess her up Lou Lou don't don't touch
her burritos
don't this is going really
smoothly what's going on so did she
already get one yeah she'll never what's
the time what if I take one she'll never
make the record not she break she'll
break
not aord we're going to see how many how
long it takes her to finish this it's
exciting it is it is exciting I was
getting a head shot you were getting one
head shot you were taking a picture I
was getting new head shot you could sit
down for a second I was taking I was
getting new head shots and this time I
was going to do it with makeup cuz I've
seen what it does for you I'll take you
always have your best material L when
you're off off camera what
it is a big
box are we still on number two is there
any music you can put in the background
that's uh that's uh we don't want to pay
for it she 10 she's going to eat
10 and she she's been
130 no 140 and she's on number three she
doesn't talk much does
she I said the last going to keep
replaying
I said the last time can you imagine if
this was like a a
[Music]
date they're saying someone unwrap them
for her I feel like we should have
unwrapped them like it's going to take
up at least 10 seconds that's your
biggest problem is that they're not that
they're
wrapped w we blew
it can we stop can we not do the music
why I like it it's good right the music
with it
yeah she yeah she likes the music okay
it just keeps her going the music is our
theme music they're asking what is it
and why wouldand made it my husband made
the music and you said please stop it
please stop
it so ladylike how many has she uh
finished I can't see I don't know I'm
not on a good angle guys in the back do
you know how many she's had how many
rappers are there well there's one two
three four five six burritas left so
she's had four she's had four burritos
already this is amazing almost 3 minutes
they're starving kids in
[Music]
Mexico why do you always bring up
the the negative I did see a comment
about that like uh before that it's such
a weird sport to have when there's so
many starving people all over the world
don't
listen no they're saying this is so
unhinged please stop
music the music's too loud oh all of a
sudden everybody you're all producers
the music's too loud what do you want to
hear the chewing is that what you want
to
hear I'll I'll make the sound effects
I'll do the sound effects you do they
you what no no this is Realty for your
music oh they look yeah they know what
they're doing we have a lot of people
back
there I think the dog
want thank you Ricky T he says get Zack
Lewis to write us some
music my husband does it for a
living that's disgusting
dad there hasn't been any jumping
yet
this gives me so much
anxiety why I don't know cuz the feeling
of being that
full I think I just feel it and it gives
me anxiety I like doing the sound effect
I'm dubbing the eating it's good they're
saying please stop Howie Howie please
Howie please stop it's so realistic it
is I'm going to do more I'm not going to
listen I'm not going to listen to you
you're the throat goat I'm the throat
goat yeah who's calling me I don't
[Music]
know this is worse in the prolapse
they're
saying people are
leaving Time 5 minutes and 20 seconds
what is the record what is the record we
I don't know the record we're just
seeing how many she K
or how much time it takes
eat I have zero control over my dad my
name may be on this podcast now but I
have zero control over him it's so gross
it's so gross droke go
[Music]
I wonder why she doesn't have to like
make room this time like it's with the
um dumpl
e it is a the dumplings there was a lot
of movement and jump jumping yeah seems
a lot more leisurely this is easier
there's not that many left there's only
three left I don't think he's eaten
since
dumpling what no she has I follow her
she's eating a lot yeah she just went to
the bathroom right before this oh okay
Mr rainbow love paid you $5 to knock it
off Dad for five bucks for five bucks he
said knock it
off I'm thinking I'm thinking $5 is
$5
[Music]
how many are left Alex he didn't say for
how long the knock three left yes I'll
do the last that means she's done seven
already Yes in 5
minutes right is this also on in the
lobby seven 7 Minutes s and seven
minutes so we're averaging one burrito a
minute I think so we're airing it live
at Taco
Bell I don't know if there was a record
for most how fast you can eat 10
burritos uh John Edward is
here can you follow this up I don't know
if you can follow this up if she
finishes all these and then drops dead
we could still talk to him yeah that's
not funny
that's she's slowing
down saying I'm doing it no pressure
though no pressure no pressure you can
do this you got this enough people are
going believe I lost people are going I
lost I
lost a lot of people said 5 minutes
that's why this is crazy you're
amazing oh she okay oh my
God wait oh what started again okay two
more two more two more two more we're at
8 minutes and 15
seconds oh she's wearing a booer
that's a boo hey buddy her mouth is here
her mouth is up here Lou's looking at
the
wrong you got
$9.99 to keep going dad dad keep going
with your sound effects for
$9.99 I'm
going Dad okay Rick for $10 says keep
the noises going Dad $10 keep them
going
is that a double she's doing a
double yeah that's two it's the last two
oh my God doing a double she's double
fisting I think she had stop that you're
my daughter you don't talk like that in
front of your father I don't want to
hear how many times have I told you Dad
$10 for those
sounds No double fisting jokes in front
of
you do you think this turns people on do
you think this turns you guys on yeah
is this a
fetish they're saying Rick what the [__]
hasz he paid $10 for the
sounds people paid for this and I'll do
what I'm paid to
do John Edward must be so happy he's
back there are you happy he walked down
look what you're following he
walked he's wearing a mask so he can
puke in it
with can she do it in 10 minutes we have
5 Seconds we have five what no she can't
do it in 10 minutes five more seconds to
10 minutes
$19 for to do what to stop it stop stop
Dad no more sounds with peace and love
from Iron
Sam $191 19.99 just stop it
sale
what when she raises her her hand that
means stop it I'm going to leave it up
to her when she raises her hand Wonder
disgusting Lou Lou you don't do that no
I did that because I'm watching
somebody's eating here I know that's
true that is so
true all right almost there she doesn't
care
taking your arm getting tired Alex my
son is holding the camera oh we tell her
we don't have all [__] day
[Laughter]
here
[Music]
$10 Gizmo Kaka after all those burritos
what does that
mean oh Bill gave you $10 to do Gizmo
I you work for tips
D I'm making it rain wait lotus lotus
what are you done hands up Lotus don't
listen to Iron Sam bring the soundtrack
back $20
Applause how what was the time what was
the time I can't see look 1121 21
seconds 11 minutes 21 seconds 10
burritos how do you feel you got a
coupon there one of the coupons for her
yeah yes yes you get to pick your price
you want no no no I know what I want to
give her I listen a coupon just one yeah
she gets one coupon yeah but I'm giving
you a coupon do you think she even wants
food breakfast burritos on us at Taco
Bell thank you I appreciate it thank you
Taco
Bell